mais d'abord donc le nouveau
gouvernement décortiqué par samia de
chiens
il est désormais au complet le nouveau
gouvernement s'est réuni cet après midi
pour son premier conseil des ministres
autour d' emmanuel macron la nouvelle
équipe formée par elisabeth bornes passe
de 27 à 41 membres dont 20 femmes cinq
ministres du précédent gouvernement
manquait à l'appel amélie de montchalin
brigitte bourguignon et justine bénin
battu aux législatives il ya elles
broutent iv qui a pris la tête de
l'assemblée nationale et damien abad
visé par une enquête pour tentative de
viol il paraissait préférable faso
calomnie ignoble dont je suis la cible
orchestrée dans un calendrier bien
choisi jusqu'à ce matin encore que je
puisse le défendre sans entraver
l'action du gouvernement damien abad
cède son fauteuil de ministre des
solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées à jean-christophe
combes directeur général de la
croix-rouge au moment de céder sa place
brigitte bourguignon n'a quant à elle
pas pu retenir ses larmes elle laisse sa
place au médecin urgentiste françois
braun nouveau ministre de la santé autre
nouveau venu au gouvernement olivier
klein maire de clichy sous bois issu de
la gauche 2-1 ministre du logement
caroline cayeux maire de beauvais
étiqueté à droite et la nouvelle
ministre délégué aux collectivités
locales le gouvernement born 2 est aussi
issu d'un jeu de chaises musicales entre
ministres de l'équipe précédente
christophe béchu jusqu'ici en charge des
collectivités territoriales devient
ministre de la transition écologique en
remplacement d'amélie de montchalin
notre responsabilité sera donc dans tous
les domaines que je viens d'évoquer en
liaison étroite avec agnès panière une
hache et sous l'autorité d'elisabeth
bornes de faire progresser cette grande
cause du quinquennat olivier vers ans
quitte le ministère des relations avec
le parlement pour devenir le porte
parole du gouvernement un poste
jusqu'ici occupé par olivier grégoire
qui rejoint bercy comme ministre
déléguée au commerce à l'artisanat et au
tourisme
deux autres ministres délégués à
l'europe et aux affaires étrangères
changent de portefeuille franck riester
qui récupère les relations avec le
parlement et clément bonnet le nouveau
ministre des transports
et puis il ya ceux qui ont été confortés
dans leurs fonctions
bruno le maire reste numéro 2 du
gouvernement au ministère de l'économie
et des finances gérald darmanin garde le
ministère de l'intérieur et voit son
périmètre élargi aux outre mer eric
dupond-moretti reste à la justice
catherine colonna à l'europe et aux
affaires étrangères olivier dussopt pts
au travail pape n'diaye à l'éducation
nationale marc fesneau à l'agriculture
rim abdul malik est la culture gabriela
talent aux comptes publics et malgré des
accusations de viol qui pèsent sur elle
crise ou l'asacar au pont nous conserve
son titre de ministre délégué à la
francophonie et puis enfin il ya celle
qu elisabeth bornes n'avait pas intégré
à sa première équipe et qui font leur
retour au gouvernement marlène schiappa
l économie sociale et solidaire et
geneviève darrieussecq aux personnes
handicapées et on tire ensemble de
leçons de ce remaniement avec catherine
tricot bonjour catherine bienvenus vous
êtes directrice édition de la revue
regards et votre dernier numéro en voilà
une qui s'affiche emmanuel macron en
portrait un peu violent comme une un jeu
on en parlera qu'elle sera l'alternative
on en discutera ensemble tout à l'heure
jean garrigues l'historien président du
comité histoire parlementaire hauteur de
la tentation du sauveur histoire d'une
passion française aux éditions payot
emmanuel rivière bonsoir bienvenue le
directeur international pour les études
politiques de l'institut kantar public
et matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique bienvenue à vous aussi une
question générale pour commencer
catherine quel adjectif tient pour
qualifier ce remaniement je me dis moi
comme ça tout de suite faux semblants
faux semblants oui écoutez on nous
annonce une gouvernement paritaire et
puis sur deux dit secrétaire d'état ya
un hommes et neuf femmes parité entre
nous et on peut dire en plus voilà c'est
à dire que les hommes ils sont ministres
et des femmes et son secrétaire ben ça
ça ça sonne bien regarder le régalien on
a d'ailleurs une infographie
c'est formidable à une femme pour pour
5,6 alors gagner pour effectivement 42
ministres en attendant l'intrigant
isabelle borne la parité et là c'est un
peu un trompe l'oeil et puis on a vu un
ministre de la planification écologique
ça a duré un mois la planification
écologique quoi s'est terminé au bout
d'un mois donc on a l'impression quand
même que s'il ya beaucoup de
communication dans ces recompositions
voilà c'est le premier mot qui me vient
il en est d'autres applis mais on va on
arnaque du temps pour l'analyse elle
tombe bien jean garrigues pas de
surprise on peut dire ça comme ça avec
ce nouveau gouvernement mais en même
temps est-ce qu'il fallait en attendant
non non je peux on a beaucoup parlé de
grande coalition etc c'était absurde on
savait très bien ça ne se réalisera pas
et que là on a un gouvernement de repli
sur sur l'espace de ce qu'on appelle la
macro ni et qui fait un peu plus de
place mais c'était là aussi attendus aux
partenaires d'ensemble c'est à dire au
modem et et horizons avec un petit peu
d'agir au cip secrétaire donc tous les
partenaires songe à dire sont servis
c'est finalement assez classique sous la
vème république quand vous avez une
coalition majoritaire
il ne faudrait surtout pas oublier de
penser aux partenaires mais là dans la
conjoncture actuelle avec cette majorité
relative c'était d'autant plus crucial
de d'écouter d'entendre les
revendications qui est peut-être même
aller au delà d'ailleurs des partenaires
et justement emmanuel rivière est ce que
ce
nouveau gouvernement bornes numéro 2 est
ce qui tient compte du résultat des
législatives ou deux
de l'échec des négociations si tenté
qu'il y en ait eu poste législatives ce
que je veux dire on pourrait
effectivement se demander si on aurait
eu un gouvernement très différent si
ensemble avait disposé d'une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale c'est pas si sûr
en fait c'est vrai que dans le résultat
de la législative il y aurait pu y avoir
dans les attentes des français notamment
l'idée que mes seins par nécessité la
majorité a laissé de s'élargir à les
faire rentrer des représentants mais des
partis qui représentait l'opposition au
moment des législatives c'est pas le cas
non je pense qu'il ya jamais eu ce
scénario très très sérieusement mis sur
la table donc je suis pas sûr que c'est
susciter une attente tel qu'aujourd'hui
les français seraient déçus peut-être
que ceux qui sont le plus déçu c'est
effectivement ce qui au sein la majorité
ont constaté qu'ils avaient du mal et
c'est vrai que l'impression que ça donne
mais c'était déjà le cas lors de la
composition du premier gouvernement de
bornes c'est que c'est pas facile en
fait de réunir un casting qui et c'est
personnalité très visible qui ont noté
un effet sur l'opinion publique il
envoie un message très très clairs comme
c'est normalement le cas d'un
gouvernement nommé à l'issue d'une
présidentielle mais si on regarde donc
42 membres je rappelle ses y compris
elisabeth bornes ce qui vous avez bien
écouter sujet de sa mère déchirée par
les 2,41 donc ses 42 avec la première
ministre seize ministres 15 ministres
délégués 10 secrétaires d'état la moitié
étaient déjà dans la première équipe
nommé le 20 mai mathieu mois en voyant
sa demie ça va pas faire gagner beaucoup
de voix à l'assemblée nationale quand il
a fallu scier le texte précis un petit
côté
deuxième division notre gouvernement non
mais quand on se re projette cinq ans en
arrière et avait des personnalités
publiques à nicolas hulot il est
françois il y avait deux poids lourds
politiques et françois bayrou il y avait
une surprise c'était le premier ministre
edouard philippe puis il y avait des
prisonniers enfin bruno le maire mais
voilà là c'est plutôt des gens que l'on
les visages ne sont pas connus des
français ça ne veut absolument rien dire
de leurs compétences là où ils sont mais
c'est juste qu'en terme de d'impact
d'image complètement d'accord avec
amalia ça ne crée rien alors ensuite
c'est toujours un signal politique un
gouvernement est ce que il a entendu le
message des français
la question aujourd'hui je pense pas que
le gouvernement a été très différent si
jamais il n'y avait pas eu ce score aux
législatives
on voit si la priorité avait été de
rassembler on vient de toute façon
l'union nationale qui avait été un temps
envisagée ou évoqué avec certains
leaders ou la coalition ça c'est fini ça
aurait pu se traduire éventuellement par
les ouvertures mais ça marche plus comme
ça la politique aujourd'hui donc donc
c'est pas ce message là en tout cas
qu'il a entendu est ce que c'est un
gouvernement pour réformer pour
enclencher une dynamique avec une
coloration politique particulière bain
bah enfin différentes en tout cas de ce
qu'on a connu non non plus dans la
coloration politique c'est la même les
équilibres au sein de la majorité maman
relatif présidentielle sont sont
conscients qu'on conserver devoir
consolider et il n'entend pas de grand
réformateur avancé que la réforme va
être beaucoup plus difficile à passer
compte tenu du score aux législatives
mais il n'y a pas une impulsion une
dynamique un gouvernement d'action sur
les mots consorts on verra bien à usage
en séries viennent d'être nommés ça
donne mais il le fait qu'on connaisse un
peu déjà la plupart des la plupart des
gens avec les autres soient vraiment
inconnu à part quelques spécialistes et
là c'est peut-être une patte de
maquereaux nice avait cherché pour pour
la santé un spécialiste du sujet houleux
l'ancien patron de la croix rouge on l'a
vu qu'il remplace damien abad pour les
solidarités là c'est plutôt des
techniciens pour le reste quel élan
politique quelle couleur politique
quelle lecture politique donnée à ce
gouvernement j'en suis pas tout à fait
capable et améliore a pas énormément
l'évoqué
jancigny si les partis qui forment la
coalition présidentielle effectivement
il ya quatre ministres modem deux
ministres horizon 2 pour agir et un pour
le parti radical
catherine tricot ils sont un peu mieux
traités ou finalement c'est à peu près
la même chose c'est parti allié on va
d'ici sont ils traités par rapport à
précédemment juste précédemment c'est
certain qu'ils sont bien traités mais je
vous dis pas le choix ils ont déjà fait
une majorité relative si en plus tout le
monde et pas rassembler là je pense que
ça va mal moi j'ai quand même relevé
l'arrivée de franck riester à la relance
et aux relations avec le parlement qui
donne quand même à une indication ils
savent que c'est là que ça va se jouer
que ça va se jouer à droite oui parce
que vous rappeler tout le monde n'est
pas au courant que fonds créé un tiers
vient de cette famille politique il
connaît bien tous les députés où la
plupart députés qui sont sur les rangs
de
donc tout parler à la droite il fallait
un ministre qui viennent de la droite
que n'était pas le cas de l'est vers ans
donc on a débarqué olivier ferrand et
mais franck riester pour aller essayer
de construire des majorités autour de
textes ça ça me paraît être vraiment il
reviendra consacré un chapitre un zoom
sur les on va dire les personnalités un
peu marquante et notamment olivier
ferrand mais moi je pense à françois
bayrou qui depuis quoi deux trois quatre
semaines faisait régulièrement entendre
son mécontentement est ce que vous
diriez que là il a été entendu bien
traité par elisabeth borné par le prénom
république oui je pense qu'effectivement
dans les équilibres que vous venez de
rappeler le mode nc s'y retrouvent ils
s'y retrouvent aussi d'ailleurs au à
l'assemblée nationale puisque dans la
déconfiture qui a été celle de la
majorité le modem a réussi à préserver
ses troupes donc de ce point de vue là
aussi la sanction ou pas positive les
résultats des législatives
patrick mignola effectivement pas le
patron en panne à 30 du groupe le coup
c'est le choix des électeurs et pas
celui des investitures donc je pense pas
que le modem puisse s'estimer du tout
mal traitée la question qui se pose
c'est évidemment comment continuer à
peser par rapport dans l'univers de la
majorité ce que ce que françois bayrou
est toujours cherché à faire c'est à
dire faire entendre une voix spécifique
et un apport spécifique et la
contribution du modem mais je ne sais
pas si votre institut spécifiquement
laver laver étudiée mais on avait vu
dans les sondages ces derniers jours
passé une demande de la part d'eads et
des personnes qui étaient qui était
interrogé de d'élargissement notamment
de ministres verts enfin bon c'était une
espèce de devenait impossible à réaliser
alors c'est là où ça va être très
important de suivre comment cette
attente de l'opinion publique va se
concrétiser dans des faits avec des
circonstances qui me semble un peu
contraire par rapport à cette attente
qui était de dire finalement puisque il
n'y a pas de majorité on va avoir des
politiques un peu plus composites
peut-être un peu moins violente
peut-être un peu moins tranchantes et du
coup qui prendront davantage en compte
la diversité des uns et des autres et
c'est vrai que on décrit souvent la
france comme extrêmement polarisé
faudrait pas négliger sa demande très
profonde d'arriver à ce qu'on mette
d'accord d'arriver à trouver c'était un
peu d'ailleurs l'essence même de la
macro ni au départ et des aidants marche
arrivé à prendre les compétences un peu
de chaque côté en se disant que en
abordant de la manière de les choses
d'une manière documentée plus
pragmatique et plus et les coutumes y
arriverait et voilà ça c'est la demande
des français et c'est avec ça que le
gouvernement et la majorité maintenant
doivent avancer c'est à dire se rappeler
qu'on n'espère qui aura un élargissement
alors si elle se trouve pas dans la
composition gouvernementale
c'est vrai que c'est une première
occasion karaté est ce qu'elle pourra se
retrouver dans les politiques telles
qu'elles seront conçus ce sera plus
compliqué à mon avis mais c'est sale
attente l'indépendance du pays ne se
fera pas sans réformes profondes voilà
ce que
le chef de l'état a dit juste avant le
conseil des ministres une courte
séquence qui a été filmé et diffusé en
direct
sur les chaînes d'info mails macron qui
a acté on va l'écouter le refus des
partis d'opposition de participer à ce
gouvernement
la première ministre m'a rendu compte
vendredi du résultat des consultations
conduites la semaine dernière
il convient de prendre acte de l'absence
de volonté des partis de gouvernement de
participer à un accord de gouvernement
voilà il s'avère c'est drôle parce que
la transmission s'est coupé pile à ce
moment là où à la fin de cette phrase
parce qu'en fait c'était pas prévu que
l'ensemble de l'allocution du président
soit diffusé catherine tricot le chef de
l'état l'a et savez sans doute être le
jeu auquel on va assister les uns les
autres dans les prochaines semaines dans
les prochains mois fait porter la
responsabilité de au parti d'opposition
mais est ce qu'il a vraiment donné à il
avait d'abord d'une mission de
négociation
je pense que tout le monde sait que
c'était un peu bloqué la situation dans
la mesure où les notamment les
républicains ont fermé des portes de
façon ce qui était pas mon hypothèse là
je l'avais même exprimé ici sur ce
plateau en pensant moi je pensais qu'il
y avait des bases objectives pour un
accord politique avec et vous pensez que
l ère allait rentrer dans un jeu pensé
je pensais que il y aurait des forces
sociales jeudi rond dirons-nous qu'ils
allaient pousser vers cet accord et que
finalement ça ne s'est pas fait
donc je moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment que
d'une part c'est pour ça qu'on met
franck riester parce qu'il va falloir
quand même essayer de tenir le plus
longtemps possible mais il me semble que
tout le monde maintenant se préparer à
ce que ça ne tiennent pas c'est à dire
qu'on va pas faire cinq ans dans cette
situation et que donc le jeu de qui va
porter le mistigri de la suite de
l'histoire et comment a commencé et
c'est pour ça que marine le pen n'arrête
pas de faire de répéter qu'elle ne fera
pas obstruction donc elle ne veut pas
porter le chapeau de la responsabilité
du blocage emmanuel macron renvoie ça
renvoie tout le monde aux ados que la
nuque baisse dit on et des meilleurs
opposants etc hier chacun commence déjà
à construire les arguments de la
prochaine campagne qui aura lieu dans
six mois dans un an dans 18 mois on ne
sait pas mais qui aura lieu jean
garrigues c'était trop trop trop tôt
trop vite on n'avait pas à prendre la
culture du compromis en quinze jours il
ya une opportunité historique pour
réhabiliter ce que c'est que le
parlement est peut-être martin a
beaucoup dit ça
c'est très très lente et seddik aux
l'exécutif ni côté personnes
effectivement ils sont tous paralysés
d'abord par leurs réflexes et par la
polarisation qui a permis à certains
partis malgré tout de s'imposer dans le
paysage politique c'est par la
poldérisation qui sont venus ils vont
pas y est ils ont failli renoncer
aujourd'hui et d'autre part parce que il
ya le spectre de cette dissolution et
que donc personne en tout cas dans
l'opposition n'a intérêt à manifester
une sorte de proximité avec le pouvoir
une convergence voir une compromission
si on veut espérer après la dissolution
sentirez bien d'une bonne manière de
bien bien pour fait profitable donc
voilà on est quand même dans quelque
chose qui a un jeu qui est quand même
extrêmement bloqués
je n'aimerais pas être dans la dans la
poudre d'elisabeth bornes parce que je
crois qu'elle dise quoi qu'elle fasse
quoi que ce soit son son programme sa
déclaration de politique générale elle
va être de toute manière entravé par ce
par cette hypothèque emmanuel rivière
d'accord pour dire que c'est peut-être
là dessus que l'opinion va juger les
prochains mois à la fois l'action du
gouvernement et la responsabilité d
opposition s'est dit il ya peut-être une
demande de compromis ou de vous montrez
nous que vous êtes capable de travailler
ensemble donc c'est irresponsable moi
c'est ça va être ça la stratégie des uns
et les autres c'est d'accord là dessus
absolument et ça va être en gros quel
jeu joue et pour se présenter nos
meilleurs conditions si jamais on
constate le blocage locales ce qui
peut-être l'infime chance pour que ça
marche d'ailleurs d'un côté vous avez
l'opinion publique y est l'ol il ya une
autre circonstance quand même c'est que
on a bien compris à l'issue de ces
législatives que notre mode de scrutin
grâce tissint en aucun cas une majorité
il ya d'autre systèmes politiques autour
de nous ou bas on peut provoquer des
élections législatives c'est le cas en
italie c'est le cas en espagne
d'ailleurs c'est le cas aussi à la
knesset
kaki en tête je peux me tromper mais qui
en fait un cas de majorité introuvable
qui suite à une dissolution a donné une
majorité trouver
je pense qu'il ya des bons connaisseurs
de l'histoire et de la géographie
politique aime surtout que ça manque pas
de sel on est tous ces partis qui
défendent la proportionnelle et qui sont
un fichu de se mettre d'accord
quand on sort du fait majoritaire nous
en considérant que les autres ont
toujours tort que c'est nous les bons
qu'eux et les mauvais c'est incroyable
comment les vieux réflexes de partis
comme le rassemblement national comme la
france a soumises qui qui sont porteurs
de cette rénovation démocratique en or
mais oui il faut être une démocratie
moderne et qui sont là ils ont un cas
d'école et aucun d'entre eux n'est
capable et le présent les modèles ma
compagne
éco-responsabilité katrina mais tout à
l'heure vous avez remarqué que la
tribune lave une de regard
pascal enjeux les reçus elle est dure et
puis moi je vois cette cette une le
portrait du président je le dis bah
c'est quoi le message il faut caillassé
macro non non non c'est une france c'est
une france totalement éclatée moi je
pense qu'on est dans une france fracture
et je n'ai plus comme ça à leur banque
cammas est intéressante donc le message
que voulait faire passer c'est que c'est
que on est dans un pays qui est éclatée
mais dans un niveau de tension ces
tunnels est violente et les violences
parce qu'on est dans sa main j'entends
ce que vous dites c'est vrai c'est à
dire que ya l'espoir qu'on va trouver un
consensus et moi je pensais que
l'écologie pourrait être la base de ce
consensus parce que probablement que
c'est ce qui réunit le plus largement
les français en ce moment mais on peut
pas dire que ça on prend vraiment le
chemin tout cas l'affichage politique
n'est pas celui-là mais donc on a un
pays qui aimerait pouvoir se retrouver
mais qui pour l'instant est
incroyablement fracturé fracturé et
socialement fracturé dans ses
préoccupations et fractures et
politiquement ce que vous avez dit sa
maman la montée de l'extrême droite est
absolument sidérantes on a une gauche
qui se fait corner risée comme jamais la
gauche devient l'extrême gauche parce
que quand même assez assez étonnant
c'est dire que la gauche ne serait donc
plus une alternative pour le pays c'est
quand même ça bloque aussi le jour de
votre bouche bah moi je pense que je
pense que je pense que d'appeler contre
ngos lanouf est je pense qu'avec ap l'ex
traoré shenyang c'était c'est très
contestable et que ça bloque
complètement le virage il ya en tout cas
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on est
dedans on est devant des divisions et
une fracturation politiques qui semblent
d un espace poétique et irréconciliables
et c'est ça c'est moi je c'est une
responsabilité mené le maquereau
si c'est ma vie j'étais là une donc vous
pensez qu'il est principalement
responsable solide en lecture en mai ce
que si on part de ce principe là on
n'arrivera à rien et que précisément
dans une situation de crise
exceptionnelle comme la nôtre alors je
vais pas faire un parallèle avec la
l'après seconde guerre mondiale mais il
ya quelque chose à recréer quelque chose
à créer de la confiance envers le envers
la politique et ça veut dire que chacun
doit y mettre du sien est dans une
situation comme cette situation elle est
idéale pour que chacun puisse y mettre
du sien parce que on peut se permettre
d'aller discuter texte par texte le
projet sur projets et moi je pense qu'il
ya quand même du grain à moudre je veux
dire que dans un sens comme dans l'autre
alors c'est vrai que le principe de ce
que faisait michel regarder des
majorités d'idées majorité la majorité
stéréo comme le disait le juriste guy
carcassonne c'est un peu compliqué
aujourd'hui parce que quelquefois rocard
aller chercher sa majorité chez les
communistes d'autrefois au centre droit
c'est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus compliqué parce que des personnes
que ce soit à gauche ou à droite n'a
intérêt à jouer à jouer ce jeu mais moi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui enfin face aux
enjeux énormes qui qui qui se posent
devant nous il ya peut-être une
possibilité justement d'utiliser à
j'allais dire cette fragilité du pouvoir
pour essayer de faire passer quand même
je peux dire juste un petit monde sait
que c'est ça le problème des faux
semblants tautologie c'est un
gouvernement qui renvoie du
faux-semblant sac si on veut
véritablement eu mes loisirs à sa
plomberie les oppositions aussi nommé
s'en sont elles prêtes à vraiment
négocier sur un programme pour l'instant
on ne connaît pas on ne connaît pas
vraiment le programme d' emmanuel macron
et quand il envoie un message et il
envoie un contre message en même temps
je peux dire tout ça quand il dit je
vais faire de la planification
économique écologique et ça dure un mois
enfin je veux dire c'est que il ya
quelque chose qui est qui est il qu'ils
qu'est ce qu'il veut sûr qu'on peut se
mettre d'accord cercle il renvoie
l'opposition moi je pense qu'il ya quand
même une faiblesse pour ça que je pense
que c'est de son côté qu'est la
responsabilité c'est qu'à une faiblesse
du projet et de l'affirmation d'une
heure
oh là dessus et puis ensuite on passe à
oka olivier vers ans jusque faut nourrir
la réflexion a publié ce week-end le
baromètre quand un public epoca pour le
figaro magazine avec donc la cote
d'avenir la somme de personnalités et
pour la première fois depuis 40 ans
d'existence baromètre la première
personnalité à gauche c'est fabien
roussel qui montre qu'il ya une 6 points
alors que jean luc mélenchon recul si on
regarde si on compare les postures de
l'un et de l'autre depuis ces
législatives ça donne je prends un
indicateur sur ce à quoi aspire
notamment les français qui se sentent de
gauche par rapport à la posture
vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis de ce
gouvernement donc effectivement
dans les jeux des uns et des autres je
pense que les français vont être
attentif à qui jouent le jeu qui ne
jouent pas le jeu d'une possibilité de
réussir à s'entendre alors on va
regarder d'un peu plus près un certain
nombre de postes stratégiques et donc
mathieu comme promis on ont démarré
vouliez revenir avec le nouveau rôle
dévolu à olivier ferrand c'est une forme
de retour en grâce assez rapide
il ya un peu plus d'un mois au léger et
veyran paraissent un peu sur la touche
dans les mains il alors qu'il avait
occupée on s'en souvient des premiers
rôles au ministère la santé où il avait
remplacé au débotté agnès buzyn pour
devenir dans la mémoire de beaucoup le
visage du coc vide des années qu vite
d'une certaine façon pour le meilleur ça
c'était le côté le bon docteur vers ans
et que son allure fringante et ses
diagnostics
on aurait dit un médecin tout droit
sorti d'une série américaine
hospitalière et puis pour le pire
c'est-à-dire les confinements les
couvre-feux les masques les gestes
barrière monsieur mauvaises nouvelles de
la pandémie et bien sûr la bête noire
des antilles vax pour cette raison mais
aussi en raison de son ambition un peu
trop débordante selon ses propres amis
de majorité emmanuel macron l'a relégué
d'abord dans l'ombre après avoir mis
sous les projecteurs au ministère des
relations avec le parlement ça c'était
dans le premier gouvernement bornes
après tout le second tour de la
présidentielle s'était jouée en partie à
gauche pour le chef de l'état et puis
qui sait qu'un ancien député socialiste
bat ça serait pas de trop pour faire
travailler la poutre de ce qui reste de
la maison socialisme et comme très
souvent en politique
il est vite apparu que les gérants
relations avec le parlement ça
ressemblait fort quand même une erreur
de casting trop cassant trop péremptoire
pour occuper ce poste qui nécessite
quand même une patience est un art des
négociations quasi maçonnique pour bâtir
de fragile passerelles et de subtils
équilibres et puis surtout les
législatives ont rebattu les cartes ce
n'est plus vers la gauche que l'heure
d'aujourd'hui catherine le disait la
majorité c'est bien évidemment vers la
droite et donc il valait mieux un profil
effectivement comme franck riester issu
de ses rangs et qui connaît tout le
monde et qui fut le toit tout le monde
dans l'hémicycle pour faire avancer le
schmilblick est ce que c'est un meilleur
choix de placer olivier ferrand au porte
parolat oui parce que parler aux caméras
pour le coup il sait faire et ce n'est
pas faire injure olivier grégoire qui
n'aura tenu à ce poste qu'un peu plus
d'un mois baky ukraine quelques ratés
dans la communication
du gouvernement bornes alors les
circonstances étaient compliquées tout
n'était pas de sa faute bien évidemment
mais de la féra bad aux émeutes du stade
de france en passant par l'agenda
gouvernemental quand est ce qu'on aura
lieu cette fameuse loi pouvoir d'achat
ou l'attitude à venir à tenir vis-à-vis
du rassemblement national les messages
étaient quand même plutôt floue et pas
très pas très précis pas très impactant
comme on dit en langage des communicants
et comme il faut bien le dire la macro
ni ne dispose pas d'une réserve très
large de deux profils politiques un peu
fort venu et bon communicant bas on a
donc rappelé le docteur vers en signe de
son retour en grâce jeudi au début il
apporte avec lui il garde concerne le
dossier épineux du renouveau
démocratique et tout chantier dont on
parlait à l'instant dont il avait hérité
dans le premier gouvernement alors que
souvient que le précédent porte-parole
de gabriel tang n'ai rien d'autre à
faire que porter la bonne parole et puis
non je me souviens qu'après les
législatives et un écho cruel du canard
enchaîné ironise est et qui en disant
que partout on nomme olivier ferrand à
la catastrophe arrive en concluant
pourvu qu'on ne nomme pas la défense
olivier ferrand lui préférait en sourire
saurez un peu chatouilleux quand même
mais vous préférez l'interpréter comme
le fait qu'on lui confie une mission
impossible mission difficile et se
voyait plutôt en sauveur du président
mais c'est un nouveau chapitre pour la
tentation du sauveur de
la catastrophe
les esprits qu'on aime bien
sauver la france il va commencer par sa
voix sa revanche et fusion le revoilà en
pleine lumière est ce que c'est une
bonne idée non
de fait je pense que si et rivés vers
ans a réussi à trouver le crédit qu'il a
eue auprès des français à un niveau très
élevé dans les baromètres de popularité
pour un ministre de la santé dans les
circonstances difficiles que mathieu a
rappelé c'est sans doute qu'il ait
trouvé le bon ton la bonne manière
d'expliquer des six décisions d'aider
des nouvelles difficiles à entendre avec
voilà ce mélange un peu plus subtil
qu'auparavant de transparence
d'honnêteté y compris pour dire quand on
ne maîtrisait pas la spéciation qu'on ne
savait pas ok peut-être quelque chose
qui a fonctionné déjà comme porte parole
parce que quelque part olivier ferrand a
été un peu le porte parole de la gestion
sanitaire du gouvernement pour la clé du
coffre le pic de keziban et le pic est
effectivement et les gens et de garrigue
il garde le matelas 10e ce portefeuille
du renouveau démocratique
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire qu'il va
être en charge de ce conseil national de
la refondation c'est brock est paraît-il
qui va qui sera mis en place donc c'est
une belle idée en soi maintenant il faut
il faut que ça fonctionne il faut voir
qui va y participer
on attend ça peut c'est un peu comme
tout on attend de vous de voir ce que ce
qu'on concrètement les les projets quant
à la rénovation démocratique elle me
semble réellement paradoxalement elle me
semble moins urgente maintenant que les
citoyens au moment des élections
législatives nous ont montré que y
compris dans le système de la vème
république on pouvait arriver à trouver
une forme d'équilibré de composition
d'une assemblée nationale qui soit un
peu à l'image du corps électoral à tout
à fait mais ça s'en rapprocher ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'ils aient pas un
immense trash entier là dessus alors
s'en allait forcément jusqu'à la 6ème
république parce que justement la vème
république nous montre qu'on peut
essayer de faire quelque chose et de
transformer un petit peu là le jeu
démocratique au sein de la vème
république
mais incontestablement il va falloir
réfléchir à une dose de proportionnelle
ao peut-être au rééquilibrer les
pouvoirs du président de la république
et du premier ministre pour revenir un
véritable chef de gouvernement parce que
quand vous avez un système qui repose
sur la le le le la délibération au sein
de l'assemblée le le premier ministre et
le chef d'une majorité parlementaire
c'est celui qui doit a priori à voir là
la confiance d'une majorité
parlementaire c'est donc lui qui doit
avoir le premier rôle et on pourrait
imaginer que dans ce second quinquennat
emmanuel macron comme on se retire un
tout petit peu de sa fonction d'
hyper-président parce que maintenant
depuis depuis sarkozy c'est ce sont des
hyper président et qu'il ce qu'il aille
un petit peu vers le domaine réservé des
affaires étrangères de la défense mais
ça c'est compter sans le tempérament
aussi du président de la république ça
pour dire que il ya ya je pense en tout
cas dans les pratiques et puis dans le
renouveau de même des institutions il ya
quand même quelque chose à faire
aujourd'hui et que peut-être que la
banque pourrait justement trouver des
majorités
je dirais opportune avec quand même un
risque catherine tricot c'est delà de la
réforme à petit pas c'est à dire que oui
force de discuter si le trouver une
majorité
pour un texte on se met d'accord sur un
sur un service minimum auquel cas alors
il ya ce premier risque là mais il ya
aussi un risque quand on fait la
politique deviennent simplement un jeu à
l'intérieur de l'hémicycle
la politique c'est beaucoup plus que ça
et c'est pour ça que le renouveau
démocratique ce n'est pas simplement une
question de rééquilibrage entre
l'assemblée le premier ministre
président c'est quand même ce qui avait
été racontée par emmanuel macron quand
il avait annoncé son sam composition
c'était quand même d'intégrer dans la
vie démocratique les syndicats les
associations
les entreprises etc etc
vous parlez du conseil national de la
formation mais ce qu'ils utilisent les
citoyens à travers toutes les formes
d'organisation qui peuvent avoir et moi
ce que je fais ça c'est sasia fonctionne
pardon nous interrompt si on ne ne saute
pas entre guillemets l'obstacle que
c'est pas forcément un obstacle du
parlement c'est à dire qu'il faut que
les assemblées soit aussi associée à une
démarche mais je pense que c'est les
choses ne s'oppose pas c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de raison de deux subordonnés lunel
autre terre le fait d'associer plus
largement les citoyens bon ce qui avait
été manifesté bruyamment au monde et
gilet jaune mais ceux qui ne cessent
d'être redit par les gens qui se sentent
mis à l'écart et on parlait tout à
l'heure d'olivier ferrand moi
personnellement je ne trouve pas que ce
soit quelqu'un qui soit très
représentatif de cette ce mouvement
inclusif de la société française dans sa
diversité de d'une certaine façon madame
grégoire avait plus cette capacité là à
être une femme -
prix dans l'appart dans l'appareil
politique
lll faisait plus place elle donnait plus
ce sens je veux dire je vous dis je
l'aurais mis moi à la renouvellement
démocratique parce que ce que je pensais
qu on a besoin d'une vie des moquettes
d'une vie politique qui soit moins
institutionnel plus ouverte sur la
réalité de la france c'est à dire la
diversité sociologique en termes de sexe
que les femmes soient un peu plus
présente que dans le rôle ou face quand
même secondaires qu'on leur réserve dans
ce
pour la première fois une présente de
l'assemblée femmes on peut dire que
au lycée
contradictoire c'est à la fois un vrai
progrès ça faisait combien
trench 30 ans qui avait pas une première
dit je remercie mathieu et c'est la
première fois qu'une femme était au
perchoir c'est un vrai poète aimait on
peut pas ne pas constater que ce
gouvernement il ya
paritaire pourquoi pas dire non plus que
mais il est quand même dauphin je veux
dire laisser tous les goûts les postes
principaux régaliens sont tenus par les
hommes et des femmes sont secrétaires ne
m'excuse mais écrire l'attrait d'une
famille il en est d'accord d'accord rien
y en a une j'entends bien mais ça ne
suffit pas à régler le problème j'ai
aussi mon éveil a été ministre ça n'a
pas fait baisser de cette époque là une
époque féministes n'ont pas du tout
combien mais elle apporte l ivg ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il faut plus que
ça et donc ce que je pense c'est que le
renouveau démocratique c'est la jeunesse
et les femmes c'est le monde populaire
c'est une diversité une fois de façon
prendre les décisions et ça ne peut pas
se réduire à l'assemblée nationale
vraiment
il y avait ce qu'on peut faire dès les
assemblées délibératives des ja ses
productions de la loi par les citoyens
etc il ya un champ énorme mais faut
faire attention parce que la démocratie
participative
c'est bien c'est un idéal c'est ça peut
être très très productif mais
aujourd'hui que quand on le voit dans
les communes et c est une toute petite
minorité des français qui participent
souvent des gens qui sont déjà allés les
retraités des gens qui ont un peu de
temps c'est quand même pas évident aussi
à mettre en place alors on va continuer
de pardon je reprends la main de
dérouler comme ça cette galerie de
portraits le trombinoscope de ce nouveau
gouvernement avec steve jourdain vous
pouvez nous rejoindre steve bonsoir
bienvenue à vous on va parler du nouveau
ministre de la santé un co vide qui
revient fort des hôpitaux à bout de
souffle qui est il ce nouveau mini de la
santé en soi brawn président de samu
urgences de france et conseiller santé
du candidat macron à la dernière
élection présidentielle pour tenter de
sauver les services d'urgences à la
proche de l'été emmanuel macron avait
commandé une mission flash le 31 mai
dernier il avait confié cette mission à
françois braun qui était chargé de faire
des propositions
ni une ni deux les sénateurs ont demandé
à françois braun de s'expliquer sur le
périmètre de sa mission les sénateurs
voulaient en savoir plus sur lui sur ses
idées sur l'avenir de l'hôpital il a
donc été auditionnés au sénat le 7 juin
et a livré son diagnostic sur notre
système de santé écoutez le notre
système de santé on l'a entendu on la
lit est à bout de souffle il à bout de
souffle pourquoi parce que nous avons un
système de santé qui est construit sur
l'offre de soins c'est quand même le
langage de l'hôpital
l'hôpital-entreprise l'hôpital qui crée
du soin mais qui ne répond pas aux
besoins et le challenge probablement
pour pour les années à venir c'est de
réussir la bascule de ce système basé
sur l'offre sur un système basé sur la
réponse aux besoins de santé de la
population et en fin de semaine dernière
françois braun a remis les conclusions
de cette mission flash à elisabeth
bornes il en ressort quoi quarante et
une recommandation pour passer l'été
dans son rapport de 60 pages françois
beaune met en avant plusieurs types de
solutions il ya une très grande idée au
coeur de ce rapport la régulation des
admissions aux urgences est décédée
était une régulation qui passeraient
soit par un tri à l'entrée des urgences
soit par une régulation en m en amont
par exemple par le standard téléphonique
du cem et françois beaune préconise
hocine bien de limiter par endroits
l'accès aux seuls l'urgence vitale cette
mesure qui fait bondir l'association des
médecins urgentistes mais qui était déjà
défendue est expliquée par françois
brottes devant les sénateurs écouter les
urgences ne sont pas ne sont plus ou ne
peuvent plus être le couteau suisse où
la roue de secours de tout un système de
santé qui est défaillant les urgences
doivent se concentrer sur ce que nous
savons faire la prise en charge des
patients qui requiert note expertise qui
requiert nos plateaux techniques et dans
son rapport françois brune propose
également de mieux payer les soignants
et leur comment ils recommandent de
revaloriser le travail de nuit et les
ponts du 14 juillet et du 15 août il met
aussi sur la table une prime pour les
équipes des urgences psychiatriques
pédiatrique et gynécologiques enfin
autre recommandation elle est importante
le développement de la télémédecine et
son remboursement dans tous les
départements et bien où il manquait des
médecins bref il ya beaucoup de
propositions de recommandation dans ce
rapport et les abbés doit on l'a assuré
vendredi dernier elles seront toutes
reprises par le gouvernement et puis il
faudra aussi gérer l'épineux dossier des
inégalités territoriales la feuille de
route de françois beaune est donc connue
yapluka comme on dit merci beaucoup
steve jourdain catherine tricot civile a
évoqué rapidement assas a été alors
peut-être qu'il ya là une concurrence
entre entre urgentiste mais cette
nomination a été immédiatement critiquée
par l'association des médecins
urgentistes qui parle de provocation
mouah mouah envoyant à nouveau ministre
arrivé à ce poste il ya un petit côté
mission impossible est ce que est ce que
vous leur santé comme ça va aussi ou
alors on unité historique de réformer
enfin ce secteur je ne sais pas parce
que pour reformer secteur il faut
beaucoup de conditions l'addition
politiques qui ne sont pas tout à fait
réunies semble-t-il et un briquet un
consensus enfin une feuille de route et
un consensus politique qui n'est pas là
par contre ce que je trouvais
intéressant dans ce qu'il a dit c'est il
faut transformer le système de soins
pour répondre aux besoins et la demande
sa part apparemment c'est sa philosophie
à lui et je pense qu'à lui bonne par
contre ces quarante et une proposition
c'est pas tout à fait ça encore quoi
sert pour l'instant on est quand même en
train de mettre des les p'tits
pansements des rustines vision d'urgence
pour passer
la mission sous du monde donc c'est
quarante et une mesure c'est ça mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que le
renversement qu'il propose de faire
c'est-à-dire l'hôpital de l'offre qui
est quand même
la feuille de route depuis 25 ans qui
pilote l'hôpital à un système de santé
qui va répondre aux besoins là il va
falloir vraiment inventé beaucoup il va
falloir former beaucoup il va falloir
investir beaucoup pas il va falloir se
mettre mettre de l'argent et mes du
consensus politique
je ne sais pas quelles sont les griefs
que que l'association des médecins
urgentistes ont à faire à mes chaussures
laissées sur le tri le tri aux urgences
où le tri avant les urgences
passé d urgence dans certains cas basse
est certain qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien
que l'hôpital est le dernier recours
parce qu'elle plus de médecins ouais
c'est donc c'est quand même une solution
qui est me paraît un peu brutal bon il
ya un autre poste clé dont on va parler
maintenant c'est celui du
miss de la transition écologique et de
la cohésion des territoires christophe
béchu il n'y a pas de grandes figures de
l'écologie on disait dh déjà ça lors de
la nomination du gouvernement bornes
numéro un bon ben il ya peut-être eu des
appels du pied fait yannick jadot je ne
sais pas en tout cas c'est ce qu'on a lu
et entendu les uns les autres mais voilà
il n'y a pas de grandes figures de
l'écologie 'ça ne peut lomu vous
l'analysez vous c'est un petit peu le
problème que ce trend la majorité mais
depuis 2010 sm qui a eu une grande
figure de l'écologie
de la hulot qui est partie à l'accord la
porte en disant en fait on ne peut pas
faire ce qu'il faudrait faire et j'ai
contre moi trop de force compterait donc
je reste à faire est derrière ça c'est
extrêmement difficile de trouver un
remplaçant et personne finalement pas
même marqué l'opinion en tant que
remplaçant donc c'est tout le défi de
christophe béchu à la une qui arrive à
mon avis précédé d'une absence de
réputation ni à l'échelon national les
habitants d'angers de l'agglomération et
savent qu'il a en tant qu il eut locale
mais c'est juste une partie des
solutions ce qu'on peut faire elle est l
échelon local cette réputation alors
effectivement mis en place un certain
nombre de choses positivement appréciée
donc ça c'est pour la partie cohésion
territoriale on va dire oui là son
expérience au service compris en termes
de voies vertes et de transition
écologique à l'échelon local maintenant
le défi colossal et ça fait partie des
attentes fédératrice comme le rappelait
catherine à l'échelle nationale c'est à
dire c'est pas simplement les électeurs
de la nuque qui sont très sensibles à la
question écologique est de plus en plus
de gens est le défi majeur d'ailleurs il
est pas simplement de dire il faut
s'occuper de l'écologie faire la
transition énergétique c'est d'arriver à
mettre en débat qui doit être
contributifs est doué ou doivent aller
les efforts dans ce domaine où là tout
le monde se regarde en chiens de faïence
et l'opinion qu'on se contente pour
l'instant beaucoup de regarder ce que
font les entreprises est ce que fait le
gouvernement alors quelques dates le
calendrier des prochains jours
demain réunion ministérielle autour d'
emmanuel macron sur la lutte contre
l'inflation
mercredi le discours de politique
générale d'elisabeth bornes 15 heures
assemblée nationale 21h au sénat jeudi
conseil des ministres avec le projet de
loi de finances rectificatif et puis
jeudi ou vendredi mais le maquereau qui
reçoit tous les parlementaires de sa
majorité
et puis ça a été une annonce de cette
fin d'après midi par le nouveau porte
parole du gouvernement olivier ferrand
il n'y aura pas de vote de confiance
mercredi demandé par la première mini
son écoute olivier ferrand la première
ministre ne sollicitera pas la confiance
des parlementaires il y aura une
discussion une déclaration de politique
générale suivie de débats à l'assemblée
nationale mercredi à 15h et puis en
soirée au sénat sans vote alors c'est
pas une première c'était le cas sous
raymond barre georges pompidou edith
cresson c'était le cas aussi avec michel
rocard ou pierre bérégovoy nous avons
fait un décompte a priori du nombre de
voix que la première ministre aurait été
sur de recueillir en cas de vote de
confiance nous ne sommes pas certains
que les conditions de cette confiance a
priori aurait été réunis c'est pourquoi
que je le redis nous travaillerons texte
par texte dans la durée pour pouvoir
réformer le pays et avec des coups à
prendre mathieu oui une concernant ce
s'exposer au fait qu'on la lui refuse
les ans de son gouvernement à
démissionner et sinon d'avoir une
relative confiance d'une majorité
relative qui aurait pu être aidés par
l'abstention d'un groupe pourquoi pas l
air mais pourquoi pas le rassemblement
national et là pour le coup ce
traditionnel vote de confiance aura été
minées donc oui de toute façon elle a
pas la majorité absolue au pape a lui
réclamé d'avoir la majorité des députés
derrière elle aujourd'hui ces
villes a rappelé jean garrigues c'est
pas une obligation constitutionnelle
évidemment de l'article 49 restants le
fou enfin il autorise 7,7 ce choix mais
il n'est pas obligatoire et d'ailleurs
georges pompidou couve de murville
maurice couve de murville et puis les
les trois socialistes du deuxième
quinquennat deuxième septennat de
françois mitterrand ne l'ont pas utilisé
pas tout simplement parce qu'ils étaient
en majorité relative qui n'était pas du
tout sûr d'avoir la confiance est là
d'elisabeth bande n'a pas la confiance
d'une majorité de députés elle est
majoritaire mais n'a pas la majorité des
députés avec elle donc ça paraît assez
assez logique serait un peu un rat qui
rit de de le proposer maintenant des
facto ça ça ça traduit une fragilité
mais ça c'est pas une nouveauté on le
sait depuis les depuis les élections et
puis il va y avoir un le motion de
censure déposée par par l efi qui
permettra à certains opposants de se
compter enfin voila mais qui elle enfin
en principe n'obtiendra pas les la
majorité absolue qui est nécessaire donc
voilà c'est un petit peu un jeu de un
jeu de rôle là mais bon ça fait partie
de hal et il nous reste un peu moins de
cinq minutes dans ce premier débat et je
voudrais qu'on termine en parlant de
l'exfiltration du ministre des
solidarités damien abad accusé de viol
et d'agression sexuelle il s'est défendu
lors de la passation de pouvoir cet
après midi
chacun devrait mesurer
la violence inouïe pour un être humain
pour une famille pour des proches de
telles pratiques salam ok ce très et
trop souvent relayés sans discernement
et médiatique je veux pour ma part
poursuivre mon action dans ma
circonscription et à l'assemblée
nationale pour contribuer à
l'élaboration des politiques publiques
et défendre les valeurs et les
convictions qui me sont chers la large
confiance comment accorder les
électrices et électeurs de l'ain monts
nord et m'engage
catherine tricot l'argument de la
présomption d'innocence ça ne suffisait
plus c'était plutôt nabeul absolument
est ce que je pense que j'entends tout à
fait ce qu'il dit je pense qu'il est
profondément blessé profondément meurtri
et on peut le comprendre
ceci étant il n'a jamais eu un mot
je dirais de compassion de partage de la
préoccupation de des femmes qui disent
avoir été victimes de violences
sexuelles de sa part il a continué
d'avancer sans jamais s'arrêter sans
jamais se retourner sur les femmes qui
l'ont accusé cercle il n'était pas
obligé d'aller au gouvernement puisqu'il
savait qu'il était dans ce guêpier là et
qu'il n'était pas obligé d'y aller le
gouvernement madame bornes le savez
quand elle l'a nommé emmanuel macron le
savez quand ils l'ont nommé mais donc
ils y sont allés en pensant je ne sais
pas quoi mais lui aussi le savent et
sert que pourquoi est il allé dans cette
pourquoi s'est-il mis dans cette
situation impossible et pourquoi n'at-il
jamais su régler jeudi un rapport normal
avec les femmes qui l'accusent enfin je
veux dire il il ne fait que de les
mettre en cause enfin moi je trouve
qu'il ya quelque chose qui va pas du
tout dans la gestion de cette affaire
dont son global de la part de ceux qui
l'ont nommé et de la part de celui qui a
accepté d'aller au gouvernement et qui
ensuite a trouvé comme forme de défense
que d'essayer de renverser la tacc
contre les femmes c'était pas bien
emmanuel rivière comment réagit
l'opinion face à parce qu'il ya une
accumulation d'affaires d'accusations de
l'accusation c'est vrai que l'on peut ça
peut finir par banalise je dis pas que
le faux évidemment mais ça peut finir
par banaliser dans dans l'esprit de
l'opinion publique ces affaires là
qu'est ce qu'il y avait une un ressenti
une demande de finalement c'était pas
tenable qu'un ministre accusé reste au
gouvernement
le fait est que
damien abad un fait et été au niveau de
l'ensemble des français à ce stade connu
essentiellement pour salaires sa
notoriété était relativement faible
comme n'importe quel député dans sa
situation et même s'il avait raison des
rangs du groupe et précédemment pas
comme ça qu'on se fabrique une notoriété
et donc ça ça focaliser sur quelqu'un
qui était est connu essentiellement pour
ça et c'est le fait est que les mois
était hors du champ politique c'est à
dire qu'il y avait voilà des gens qui
ressentait quelque chose par rapport à
son maintien au gouvernement
indépendamment de leur position
vis-à-vis la majorité de la ma chronique
et après là où je diverge un tout petit
peu par rapport à ce que vous me dire
catherine c'est que les faits sont quand
même d'une certaine gravité même d'une
gravité telle que dans sa position ça ne
pouvait être que soit la dénégation ça
n'est jamais arrivé soit ils pouvaient
pas faire son rot d'empathie mal c'est
difficile de faire enfin l'aïe à simuler
l'effet que jeune junior tout bien mais
tels qu'ils sont décrits me laisse pas
beaucoup de marge à dire ah désolé je
pape il
serait donc le fait est que de toute
façon je crois que c'est un mystère pour
qu'enfin on est là on sera tous d'accord
ici pour dire que il ya besoin de faire
en sorte que le milieu politique comme
un certain nombre d'autres milieux
fassent enfin le pas nécessaire pour que
des jeunes femmes militantes se sont en
sécurité lorsqu elles vont dans des
meetings lorsqu'elles vont dans des
réunions lorsqu'elles sont sollicitées
par une personnalité politique et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est encore à tout
été le cas merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat
jean garrigues je vais rappeler le titre
de votre livre la tentation du sauveur
publié aux éditions payot histoire et
puis on peut peut-être revoir la la une
la revue regards qui a suscité le débat
autour de cette table et ça pouf joël ça
prouve qu'elle touche d'une certaine
façon qu'elle sera l'alternative avec ce
portrait fracture et on va dire ça comme
ça d' emmanuel macron